[Inaudible].
Wisecrack Michael, here with the video that's long overdue.
The last of us too was one of the most anticipated games of 2020,
but it wasn't without controversy.
The game made some variable choices that made some people very,
very mad. To be honest,
we were hesitant to make a video about it because we didn't want to rehash the
same points that had already been made in a million other articles.
Videos have been making us do this.
How Austin tracked out a PlayStation and did some research for us and by
research, I mean a 36 hour last of us, two marathon,
that was definitely bad for his wellbeing,
but lead to a pretty mind blowing revelation specifically that the game does
one thing incredibly well,
it hijacks your brain's hard wiring to make you question everything you know
about empathy. Welcome to this wise,
Greg edition on the philosophy of the last of us one and two and serious
spoilers ahead. And before we jump into the minds of Ellie and Abby,
I want to tell you about another game that you should binge for 36 hours.
And that is this week sponsor raid shadow legends.
By now you have to know that this game is an awesome hero collector RPG that is
available to play on PC and mobile.
Since downloading I've become quite a professional at the PVD battles in the
arena.
It's more fun to play against other players because it's a true Testament to how
well you've equipped your team. The game is constantly changing,
and that is just one of the things that makes it so fun to play.
The most recent update includes a new advanced quest system with new rewards in
the artifact.
It where you can craft artifacts instead of having to collect them during rates,
they also release some new champions.
So if you thought you've collected them all,
you'll have to get back into the grind.
Right now they're developing the doom tower, which will be released shortly.
So check all that out today by downloading the game,
using the link in the description. If you're a new player,
you'll get a hundred thousand silver, 50 gems, 10 mystery shards,
and one free champion called slasher. The treasure will be waiting for you here,
but only for the next 30 days. So check it out today.
Now back to the show and now a quick summary in the original, last of us,
our protagonist Joel must safely shepherd the young Ellie across the country,
amidst a zombie apocalypse. Importantly, Ellie is immune from the pathogen,
infecting people and can be studied to develop a vaccine.
The only problem the doctors have to kill her in the process. So Joel murders,
those doctors saving Ellie and dooming humanity.
Part two kicks off four years later as Joel and Ellie enjoy a relatively stable
existence.
But then Ellie learns that Joel lied to her about what happened and here's where
people get mad early in the story, we switched to a new character, Abby,
the daughter of one of the doctors, Joel murdered.
She's out to a venture father, which is bad news for Joel,
who is brutally beaten to death as Ellie watches in the aftermath.
Ellie swears revenge, which I mean fair enough,
but here's where things get tricky. After Joel's death.
Our Ellie revenge quest is interrupted by approximately 10 hours of Abbey time.
We play her backstory and relive events that we already expect from Ellie's
perspective. Then Abby learns that Ellie killed her.
Ex-boyfriend her fury rekindles and she's slash we,
the players set out to track Ellie down and fight her,
which thankfully ends in a draw. Finally,
we turn to play as Ellie who leaves her comfortable domestic life to avenge
Joel,
Ellie finds Abby who is about to be crucified and decides to rescue her so
she can force her to fight one final time.
But when the moment comes to kill Abby, Ellie decides to let her live.
The game ends with Ellie alone in her now abandoned home,
playing the guitar that Joel gave to her calling the final conversation they had
that evening before he was murdered,
where she promises to try to forgive him for stopping the operation heartwarming
story. Right? Well,
not everyone was enamored with the whole 10 hours of plane as the villain,
but at the risk of making you all hate me to suggest that this move was really
cool. If only for one reason, it versus us to rethink our conception of empathy.
Here's why psychologists outlined two types of empathy.
There's cognitive empathy and affective empathy.
Cognitive empathy is when a person can imaginably take the role of another and
can understand and accurately predict that person's thoughts, feelings,
and actions. Basically. If I put myself in my roommate's shoes,
I might predict that me eating his last pepperoni hot pocket in the shower would
rightfully lead him to want to drown me in low quality marinara sauce.
But when people talk about empathy,
they're often talking about affective empathy,
affective empathy is a vicarious emotional response to perceived emotional
experiences of others ever physically recoil.
When Michael Scott does a racist acts, well,
I come to my convenience store or felt a Pang of sadness when Simba weeps over
his dead father,
that's affective empathy. This type of empathy,
that video games are great at creating, playing as a character.
It makes it all the time easier to empathize with them and feel their sorrow or
joy.
And it's our innate understanding of effective empathy that makes us feel so
uncomfortable playing as Abby.
How dare you make me feel for this monster to better understand our discomfort.
It helps to consider that effective empathy is an emotional contagion.
According to neuroscientists, Matthieu Ricard,
an emotional contagion is when a person automatically feels another person's
emotion without knowing that he or she is the one that revoked it.
And without being really aware of what has happened ever,
unintentionally yawned, because a friend yawned,
this can basically happen with emotions as well. Effective empathy,
as a result can make us lose ourselves in another person and thus lose full
control of our actions.
Perhaps nothing can explain this dilemma better than last of us itself.
In the first game, we experienced both types of empathy, right?
From the beginning, we start by controlling Joel's. As we walk in,
her shoes were being primed to associate with her.
So of course we start to root for her, but even more,
we start to feel her feelings and you guessed it.
We experience affective empathy for her, but after a surprisingly short,
while she dies and it hits hard,
we experienced the loss as something intensely personal.
The character we identified with has been taken from us.
So when we start playing as Joel who has experienced the same loss,
we just kind of get his pain.
And when Joel takes on the responsibility of getting Ellie to safety,
all these feelings come rushing back to us.
We can see the world from his perspective.
We accept it is hard outer shell with regard to Ellie,
because to let her in would be to open himself up to more suffering.
Essentially we're able to feel both cognitive and affective empathy for him.
But then in part to the creative use of controlling multiple characters is about
to complicate things a lot. As we learn simple games,
play techniques such as running, jumping,
and cautiously shuffling along Snoke or alleges.
The game teaches us with baby steps,
building us up through a connection with Abby and like the warm and fuzzy
memories we have of learning to ride a bike.
We get sucked into feeling warm and fuzzy about Abby. If we're being cynical,
the game is manipulating us into caring about this person.
We walk in her shoes and we are thrust into some pretty intense emotional
experiences with Andy as her and then our worldview
changes. Now, Abby is on a mission to kill Joel.
Not only are we completely floored by Joel's murder, but we're complicit.
I just want to do escape reality for a while via a video game.
And now I'm an accomplice in my friend's murder,
which gets us to the real question that the last of us two raises is empathy.
All it's cracked up to be in against empathy.
Paul bloom explores the limitation of our feeling for others as he defines it.
Empathy is a spotlight directing attention aid to where it's needed.
Doesn't sound so horrible, right? So what's your great Paul.
The problem with empathy is that it limits our attention and our capacity to
help to only individuals or individual events.
Remember what Ricard said about losing ourselves via emotional contagion? Well,
bloom expands the problem by suggesting that all types of things,
but the restrict our ability to think about the wider social consequences of our
very narrow spotlight.
That's why it's easy to get caught up with news stories that feature human faces
say a kid whose family can't afford to celebrate Christmas this year.
It's also very easy to donate a toy train and feel super noble and not ask
questions about structural poverty. If we're so Bewitched by empathy,
bloom worries.
This will Ventas from being able to engage in larger causes that require our
attention. Things like humanitarian or environmental causes.
This limitation is nicely displayed in the climax of the last of us two in the
ad B versus Ellie battle. At this point in the game,
we've played as Abby for 10 hours.
Maybe we've even started to empathize with her.
We liked her relationship with her pops, understand her revenge mission.
Maybe we even buy into a romantic story. I mean,
Owen seems like a cool dude, but here's the kicker.
How many of us actually wanted Abby to win? I'd bet.
Most of us actually tried to let Ellie kill us while controlling Abby,
but we were forced to try to be Ellie, because again,
this game is not pure fun escapism for that stick with animal
crossing. And here's the punchline. Our commitment to Ellie,
even despite maybe getting Abby's mission was never really challenged.
Our bond was already solidified nothing, not even a full games, length,
immersive experience through another character could shake us from our empathic
connection with Ellie.
The reason we side with Ellie is because we have already aligned with her in
Bloom's terms,
the spotlight of our attention and our aid had already been focused on her and
her mission.
Even if Abby might be justified in seeking revenge per case is moot because it's
not our cause bloom leans into his critique.
By suggesting that empathic connection can actually lead to violence,
anger and evil,
evil for bloom is caused by dehumanization and objectification and our ingrained
anger at Abby. You could be considered dehumanizing,
just scrolling through message boards shows just how much people hate Abby and
enjoy her suffering. When she's crucified at the end, it's pretty dark,
but is she beyond redemption? Can we see humanity in her?
Can we let ourselves side with her maybe after all,
what has she done to make us hate her kill Joel? Right, but Joel,
wasn't perfect. He made a pretty ethically ambiguous decision in his own,
right by saving Ellie and ended up killing Abby's father.
A doctor who was trying to save humanity from Abby's perspective,
this jerk jeopardized finding a cure for the virus and killed her dad.
So it's complicated,
but that's precisely the quandary that bloom is raising when empathy drives our
ethical standards, it often makes us dismiss the larger context,
a sort of ethical tunnel.
Swear to me that everything that you've said about the fireflies is true.
I swear this way,
the game is revealing both the power and limits of empathy,
and it's pretty cool,
but is the game intentionally playing with this to try to teach us something
about the cycle of violence. Again,
maybe bloom can help for him stepping outside of our limited empathic
connections is what he calls rational. Compassion.
Rational compassion does not deny the reality of empathy or even it's important,
but rational compassion isn't based on simply acting according to our empathy.
Instead it's built on calculated decision-making processes to get us outside our
limited empathic abilities.
So maybe we can speculate on what bloom might say about the last of us two.
We can still root for Ellie. It's natural. We are hardwired for empathy,
and we're just more invested in her,
but we can and should also pause to reflect on Abby's humanity and the
complexity of the situation.
We can think beyond the empathic connections we made with Joel and Ellie,
rather than simply condemning Abby and celebrating her crucifixion in this way.
The last of us parked two shows us how messy human connection is.
Ethical situations are complicated. It's not always so obvious.
Who's the good guy and who's the bad guy.
And maybe this is because empathy shouldn't be the ultimate source for making
ethical decisions.
Maybe we can't just rely on our immediate feelings of connection,
but at the same time, we can't just on empathy either.
There's something important about learning to see and feel the world from a
perspective that's not ours. So what are the takeaways?
Maybe the last of us part two is so divisive yet. So great.
Precisely because it throws us into the sticky,
messy world of human connection and we have to navigate through it.
Even the stuff that repulses us at times,
and like any truly immersive experience,
perhaps we've been transformed through the connections we've made broken,
resisted, and tried to simply ignore. But what do you guys think?
Should we rely on empathy to guide our personal ethics or does doing so prevent
us from seeing the bigger picture, let us know in the comments big,
thanks to our amazing patrons for all your support hit that subscribe button.
Like it's a magical source of rational compassion and as always,
thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].